[Music]
Ethan SLE made a name for himself as The
Lovable beefy Louie in Remember the
Titans but you wouldn't recognize him
today could it come to Jesus moment with
a man who once played Jesus be the
reason why if you've been following
Ethan sule's career you know much of it
has been spent playing in his own words
rolls for fat kids after Decades of
being the butt of fat kid jokes and
searching for a weight loss program that
worked SLE finally found one that stuck
and helped him get down from his
heaviest weight of over 530 lb I'm now
260 in between there there was a weight
loss and weight gain the actor has been
showcasing his new physique on Instagram
of late and fans who've been following
him for decades are finding it hard to
believe the buff guy in the pictures is
actually him so impressive is sule
transformation the actor was showas in
men's health in a January 2020 interview
he spoke candidly about his struggles to
not just lose wait but keep it off amid
a busy work schedule that didn't allow
for much time in the gym saying I wasn't
factoring in how I was going to maintain
my weight at work when I was working
like 14 hours a day 5 days a week
counterintuitively it was Supple
demanding work life that actually placed
him in a position to make healthy
changes in the first place while the
Beloved character actor is famous for
his scene stealing turns and dramatic
films like American History X and zany
sitcoms like former mustsee TV staple my
name is Earl it's one of s's most
underappreciated performances that he
actually credits with introducing him to
the gym it seems his casting on Hulu's
chance which required some weight
training combined with the revelatory
Ted talk about the science of food
helped SLE find the right mix he told
mentel the most important thing I would
want anyone to take away is that for me
the biggest change was understanding how
Food Works and the more I feel that I
understand scientifically the more power
I have over it it on chance SLE played
fan favorite Darius D Pringle opposite
Hugh Lor's titular
neuropsychiatrist on the show which only
ran for two woefully underwatch seasons
between 2016 and 2017 SLE debuted a
notably more tone physique than the one
he made famous in earlier appearances
though nothing on par with the B he's
rocking today when chance was canceled
SLE must have made a commitment to stick
to his routine at the same time Ethan
SLE was showing off his reformed figure
on chance he was also appearing in a
recurring capacity on Netflix hit sitcom
the ranch where he played Colton
Rooster's high school buddy Billy
beerpong tonkins who just so happens to
be officer tonkins now a fan favorite
guest star SLE shows up on 13 episodes
across all four seasons reminding
viewers of his genuine acting range
you're using your holster to hold a beer
yeah pretty cool huh wait where's my
gun after chance was canceled tole was
forced to find work elsewhere in 2017 he
appeared as Bill Shaker on the Twin
Peaks Revival season before playing
Tommy for six episodes in season 3 of
Santa Clarita diet from there he played
gil on good girls in 2020 and even
voiced Bob the Bigfoot on the animated
vampirina unfortunately those are the
last recurring television roles SLE has
had in the past few years sure he's
slated to appear in the Indian comedy
series The preps of Pittsburgh once the
current sag after strike ends but here's
hoping he finds his way back to a hit
show of course Ethan SLE was known for
his work on the big screen long before
he became a TV star and he's still
relatively active in Hollywood today in
2016 saple appeared in Peter bgs's deep
water Horizon alongside Mark Wahlberg
and Kurt Russell playing an oil rig
worker named Jason Anderson a few years
later he played Gilbert Coney and in
Edward Norton's period private iick
motherless Brooklyn his most
controversial feature came out in 2020
as The Plea was one of those who
appeared in the satirical political
thriller the hunt playing Gary the
conspiracy theorist podcaster with the
chip on his shoulder SLE showed off his
new look on the big screen though not
for long within the movie's first week
of release the co 19 pandemic closed
movie theaters everywhere forcing the
Blum House production underground
thankfully the failure of the hunt
didn't prevent SLE from Landing other
roles in 2022 he appeared in dog
opposite Channing Tatum and Babylon the
following year he had three movies come
out manad Drome blood for dust and the
action crime Thriller God is a bullet
since the beginning of Ethan supple's
career the actor has collaborated with
some pretty big names after Remember the
Titans he worked with Denzel Washington
again on John Q and Unstoppable
following American History X he reunited
United with Edward Norton nearly two
decades later for motherless Brooklyn
additionally he and Ashton Kutcher have
started opposite one another a few times
including the butterfly effect the
comedy short a night of 140 tweets and
the ranch but s pleas most frequent
collaborator extends back to his roots
in 1995 zle landed his first feature
film a small Indie flick directed by
Kevin Smith called M Rats from then on
sle and Smith kept working together with
the former appearing in other Smith
director Productions Chasing Amy Dogma
Clerks 2 and clerks 3 amazingly these
two have also collaborated on Project
Smith didn't direct they both appeared
in Fanboys drawing flies and vulger the
latter of which Smith executive produced
additionally Smith produced a better
place which features SLE and the two
appeared in the same a night of 140
tweet special Kutcher was in although
it's more common to see Hollywood actors
play video game characters in movie or
television adaptations since the 2010s
it's become increasingly popular to see
actors transition from the film making
world into the video game space in 2022
Ethan SLE continued that Trend playing
the mysterious Hunter Bobby in the
interactive horror game the Quarry one
part Friday the 13th one part the thing
and all parts frightening the Quarry is
a slasher game that prays upon your
fears of the unknown and stars a pretty
impressive cast to's role is somewhat
out of character for the acor but that's
part of what makes his transition to
video games so special Beyond acting
Ethan SLE has kept himself fairly busy
and not just in the gym outside of his
fitness regimen SLE hosts the podcast
American Glutton where he sets out to
examine our current obesity crisis to do
this zle is candid about his own battle
with weight loss in dietary help and
often brings on Experts and others with
similar stories to help set the stage
and encourage people to get healthy he
even runs a regularly updated blog
through the podcast's website sharing
the stories of many of his listeners
naturally American Glutton also features
a variety of celebrity guests including
those SLE has previously worked with
with folks like his Unstoppable co-star
TJ Miller former My Name is Earl guest
star Michael Pena Kevin Smith and Josh
peek The Plea does his best to break any
stigmas attached to weight loss all the
while encouraging those who feel
hopeless to push done in an interview
with Michael rosenbom on his inside of
you podcast the police shares that his
producer Kevin Connelly wanted him to
host a politically based podcast but
uninterested in sharing his political
views and fear of being cancelled he
shifted the topic entirely and from
there American Glutton was born one day
I woke up when he was asking me and I
was like oh I can fully talk about
health and fitness because I've done
that despite the personal success Ethan
SLE found in his physical trans
formation and his podcast's impact on
countless others changing his entire
look hasn't been the easiest thing for
his career speaking about the series
chance he told Entertainment Weekly back
in 2017 initially the casting directors
didn't want me to come in because I'd
lost a bunch of weight apparently they
have proposed me a bunch of times but
the casting directors were like no he's
too thin now the actor notes that after
My Name is Earl which ended in 2009 he
got down to 9% body fat by continuing ly
riding bicycles but because of his
dramatic weight loss nobody recognized
him as the same person it was then that
SLE took a different approach telling
entertainment weakly I'm not going to
kill myself to be thin when nobody knows
me as a thin person I do think it is
affecting the kinds of jobs I'm getting
and so I just kind of relaxed on my diet
but relaxing on his diet didn't mean
that SLE was unhealthy on the contrary
the actor bolts up and is at a place
where he's happy with his weight and
physique of course tole weight loss
Journey began when he started dating his
future wife Randy Lewis the younger
sister of actor singer Juliet Lewis in
2001 as SLE told people in 2022 I became
for the first time in my life kind of
interested in the future and having
experiences with her like spending a day
walking around a museum or going on a
trip or hiking that I just wasn't
physically able to do SLE went on to
explain that while he had been crazy
about lwis since the pair were teen ERS
it took her much longer to feel the same
way once she did however it was the
first time in s's life that he felt
accepted by someone for who he was as
opposed to what he looked like from
there the couple married in 2006 and
they have four daughters I was uh
possibly going to have the life that I
wanted but it required a little extra
effort on my part the support of Ethan
sule's family wasn't the only thing that
changed his perspective on physical
health in the very first episode of his
American Glutton podcast SLE recounts a
strange encounter he had with Passion of
the Christ star Jim cavel while on his
way to film Cold Mountain on the plane
cisel sat beside the actor and
confronted him on his way of life
specifically noting according to SLE
that if your life doesn't emulate Jesus
Christ you're going to hell SLE recalled
the conversation saying it was the first
conversation of that nature that I'd
ever had with somebody nobody had ever
talked to me like that nobody had ever
said look at yourself you're going to
hell you don't care about yourself at
all you're a mess SLE stated that cisel
was never unkind to him during this
encounter but nevertheless the
conversation understandably shook him
the actor recalled his feelings after
the talk saying I'm not saying he was
right or that my decision had anything
to do with Jesus Christ but my decision
was I don't want people to feel they can
talk to me like that a breath of fresh
air nowadays Ethan SLE is hard to offend
even after his incredible weight loss
Journey you're you're in these movies
and you were very you know overweight is
it or obes I was whatever you can't
offend me with those words for a long
time the actor was known because of his
overweight stature a look that helped
him land rolls and Remember the Titans
and My Name is Earl but that part of his
life is behind him now going on to say
on the timcast IRL podcast I've
definitely had some people say that I
prefer you fat and I just don't care
I had been wanting to be the size I am
now for so long that like how you want
me to be doesn't really matter using his
influence on social media through his
podcast and his physical onscreen
transformation s plea hopes to inspire
others to step up and make the change
themselves according to SLE this doesn't
necessarily require expunging foods from
your diet but rather a balance he said
on Tim cast IRL taking an entire food
group and demonizing it and cutting it
out of my life that's also extreme
[Music]